- [Instructor] Images
of a newly-discovered
species of macaque show
the monkeys grooming,
eating, and climbing.
Now, that seems reasonable.
Let's look at the other choices
just to be sure that we can rule them out.
Images of a newly-discovered
species of macaque
show the monkeys grooming,
eating, and climb.
No, that's not gonna be right at all.
If you had climb, grooming, it's the,
you just have to look
at the verb form here.
So, here, we have the
present participle, grooming,
then we have present participle, eating,
and then, we have present
participle, climbing.
We have the same verb
form for each of these,
grooming, eating, and climbing,
and so, that feels good.
If we instead replace climbing with climb,
we have a different, we have
a different form of the verb.
If we want to get technical,
we're breaking the parallel structure,
that, all of a sudden, if this was climb,
it's not the same verb form
as grooming and eating,
so, I definitely want to rule that out.
And same thing with having climbed.
So, the monkeys grooming,
eating, and having climbed?
No, it's a different,
it's a different form.
So, the monkeys grooming,
eating, and climbed?
Once again, different form.
No change is feeling good.